welcome back to my Round 4 recap from
Vegas
I'm realizing that I've had no time to
shave I'm growing a small beard I've
been spending all my time preparing
playing eating
doing Recaps sleeping
maybe at some point I'll shave but um
for this game I was playing Grand Master
Armin mccallion we both were coming into
this round with two out of three points
and I did have a little bit of time to
prepare before the game and we actually
went into one of the lines I was
predicting after D4 D5
C4 E6 as a Queen's Gambit with Knight to
F3 and in this position I played Knight
B D7 this is the so-called Barman
variation I actually don't know where
this opening got its name I think Barman
is a city in Germany uh that maybe some
like previous chest tournament was held
at some point but uh it's an interesting
line white has a lot of different
options against this move there's takes
there's E3 there's bishopath four Bishop
G5 Queen C2 uh G3 and before the game I
was checking out my opponent's chess.com
account and I saw that he's played
almost every single option against this
line so I wasn't entirely sure what to
expect but he ended up playing the move
Pawn to G3 which I did very briefly
check before the game and with this move
uh White's going for a more Catalan type
of setup and not looking to develop the
bishop the more natural way so after G3
the most principled approach is to take
the pawn because I know that this bishop
is not gonna try and recapture on C4
uh so he plays Bishop G2 and this is
still Theory I play C6 and then I was
more prepared here for castling and uh
maybe I can show some lines I was
prepping but uh he deviated from my prep
he also deviated from what he's played
before uh with the move upon A4 which I
was aware is a move and I'll go into
more details about this in just a moment
but I do want to show one of the cool
lines I Was preparing because he had a
previous game against uh Grandmaster
Bogdan dioc uh that went castling
Pawn B5 Pawn E4 and pawn B4 and there
was a really cool game like E5 Knight T5
Knight E4 Bishop E7 uh it was really
crazy where he went like all out on the
king side ended up exacting a piece but
uh Dak one with the black pieces so I
was more prepared for this type of
position which unfortunately we didn't
get
um so going back to what he played
Pawnee four
uh the one thing I remembered about this
move and probably last looked at this
move maybe six seven years ago uh I was
actually remembering I've helped a
friend prepare for a big tournament and
we were looking at this line and I had
seen a game between topolov and Gasparov
that was played in the year 2000 and I
vaguely remembered the idea that
Kasparov played he had the black pieces
of this position and I was able to
remember the next few moves from that
game after Bishop E7 castle castle E4
and in this position Kasparov played I
think a really important move Pawn E5
and this fights for the center it is a
temporary Pawn sacrifice but the point
is after it takes Knight G4 uh very
likely black will win back the pawn my
opponent defends upon with Bishop F4 and
here it's very important that black can
add another attacker with the move Queen
A5 I should know Queen C7 with attack
the pawn but that fails to pawn E6
hitting the queen so Queen A5 and this
was basically the extent of my knowledge
of the opening Theory maybe I can open
the to Paula of Kasparov game because I
was remembering that they drew pretty
quickly
and if we just flip to that game we can
see uh how that game transpired E6 take
Pawn E5 and after takes takes takes
Queen H5 Bishop D6 Knight E4 uh they
very quickly Drew from this position
with repeating moves Rook F5 Queen E8
rook f8 and neither player wanted to
fight for a win
so I have a vague memory of this
Perpetual but I couldn't remember how
they actually got to that position
and my game took a slightly different
route E6 was still played which I think
is the most principal move because white
is going to lose the pawn and white
might as well try and damage my
structure uh I take back
and rather than playing like to Paulo
with the move E5 my opponent played the
move Queen E2 and I think the idea is
very simple uh just hitting the pawn on
C4 and maybe also preparing the move
Pawn E5
so I play a move to prevent both the
white threats of playing Knight D E5
defending the pawn and block hating
White's epon
and then after it takes takes
takes takes my opponent was still
playing quickly and he played his next
move really quickly which made me
realize that he's probably still in
preparation he played the move King H1
and and this is not the type of move you
play quickly if you haven't studied the
position before like I thought the most
natural move is Queen takes C4 just
regaining a pawn but King H1 is really
interesting because ideas to play F4 and
not allow Queen C5 with Chuck and white
essentially wants to play F4 and E5 and
get this really nice Pawn chain and then
free the E4 Square for the knights or
maybe even the bishop and then
orchestrate a king side attack
yeah I took a bit of time here trying to
figure out
what the best approach should be because
if white gets in these next two moves it
can get very unpleasant for black
personalized thoughts so after a bit of
a think I decided that I would play a
prophylactic move to try and discourage
F4 and that move was Pawn to G5
and this move looks a little bit a
little bit over the top at first like
I'm pushing the pawn in front of my
castle King but I thought that if I can
prevent F4 and my queen can stay on E5
then it's not easy for white to activate
the minor pieces because these E4 Pawn
is blockaded and it restricts the Knight
and the bishop so I've tried to play in
um just a more preventive manner here
and I thought that even though I'm
creating error around my king it's not
so easy for white to immediately attack
now little did I know we're still
following a lot of like top level games
uh there was a game between galphand and
grishuk that had the same position and
we continue to follow that game uh
galphon played rook ad1 and so did my
opponent and then in this position I
played the move Pawn to B5 which I
thought is the most
um natural to hold on to my C pawn and
maybe try and eventually have some life
for this bishop the problem though is if
I ever play Bishop B7 there's Rook D7 so
it's hard to actually complete
development on the queen side but I
thought at least I'm I'm holding on to
the queen side Pawns
um and then my opponent plays a move
Pawn to F4 so this is by far the most
concrete move and uh we're still
following the game between galf Island
and grishook and I didn't know it at the
time but I'm playing all the moves that
grishook is playing now F4 it's a very
sharp move because it is a pawn
sacrifice so after it takes takes takes
I'm currently up two pawns but after it
takes takes uh if we look at the
position white definitely has a lot of
compensation given that my Bishop pair
isn't so impressive like King's very
open and the gnf files are open as well
um so there's ideas of Rook F1 or Rook
G1 white has also ideas of E5
um and my point played the move Pawn E5
in this position this is where I deviate
from the game between gal fund and
grishook apparently Grisha played the
move Rook b8s now I actually played the
top engine move in this position I
haven't had a chance to look so closely
with the engine but I know that uh the
top engine move was Pawn B4
um because after the game I I caught a
lot of commentary on my twitch Channel
with Jonathan trance and he was praising
this move that this this probably gives
black the most chances to fight back oh
he does play B4 he's incredible wait
wait he's better than 2700s
but I took some time like we can see uh
I went from 53 minutes down to 37
minutes so I was really deciding between
um mainly B4 and Rook B8 uh trying to to
see which move just creates some of
those chances for black and I like the
move B4 because it hits the knights and
if the Knight moves then there's lines
where E5 can be hanging uh so here my
opponent played an in-between move
rather than moving the knights uh he
took on C6 counter-attacking my Rook
had nothing else to do and then moved to
B8
and then he plays the move Knight E4
and this is just a really crazy position
um and during the game I realized it's a
very difficult position for black to
play because White's just so active with
the pieces and there's so many resources
to try and calculate from the lock side
with Rook F1 Rook G1 Queen H5 and F6
Knight D6 even some Bishop year ideas or
other lines where the bishop comes back
to E4 and H7 gets attacked
so it was a very difficult position to
play because any move I consider I have
to look at like so many different
options that white can play
and ultimately I decided on capturing
the pawn and this turned out to be a
really big mistake because I completely
overlooked White's idea in this position
now apparently I had two moves to keep
quality according to the engine uh the
two moves I should have chose between
Were King h8 or C3 but
um yeah from a human perspective I think
it's it's very difficult to uh to arrive
at either of these moves although King
h8 makes sense to get off the G file
um maybe in a different world I would
find this move
but after Queen takes E5 the mistake
that I made in my thought process was
that I assumed this Knight is restricted
on e4 because my Bishop on E7 is very
nicely placed to control all the squares
the Knight can move forward what I
didn't realize is white has a brilliant
tactical idea in this position which I'm
pretty sure my opponents probably saw
when he took the pawn on e4 but the idea
is after Rook G1 King h8 and I should
note that very shortly after I took the
pawn in E5 I realized what was coming
but the idea is really nice and if you
want to try and find it feel free to
pause the video this is white to move
and find just an amazing crushing move
but without further Ado the move is
Knight to G5 and here white can say oh
no my queen but if I take the queen then
it's mate and uh yeah I realized I'm in
trouble here because Knight F7 is a meat
threat and a forking threat and on top
of that my Queen's attacked and there's
really no great options here I ended up
playing Queen F5 in the game and this
just walks into Queen E5 and this is
another oh no my queen
and I was thinking of shouting out
someone call an ambulance
for me because I'm just getting thrashed
in this position
um I decided to take the queen and allow
my opponent to deliver the beautiful
Fork checkmates
uh what to do it was a rough finish but
a brilliant game for my opponent to
sacrifice two pawns and then then
sacrifice a queen twice to get uh just a
very strong mating attack and just to
note if I play a move like King G8 then
my Rook is hanging there's so many
discover checks uh yeah the black is not
surviving here
and also just to show if I would have
played Queen G7 then there's still Queen
E5 so basically wherever I would have
moved my queen queen E5 is coming and uh
yeah I just have no Escape because my
Rooks attacked Knight F7 still threats
and again if takes and checkmates
so it was a rough game
um I I think there's a lot of lessons to
take away from this game mainly the fact
that I if I go into such a sharp line I
should really be more thoroughly
prepared like remembering prep from so
many years ago did not quite cut it but
then also just having the sense of
danger to like I really should have seen
the idea of Queen E5 and eventual Knight
G5 uh before I actually took the poison
Pawn so anyway
um yeah can't be too upset I'm currently
two out of four I've been the lower rate
of players I lost to two grand Masters
been on the losing side of some very
nice games from these strong Grand
Masters so the next round starts in
two and a half hours so it's time to get
some food uh thanks so much if you made
it this far be sure to check out my twit
Channel Jonathan schrance is doing live
commentary for the morning games I'm not
sure when this recap will be posted but
just go to twitch.tv I'm Rosen to check
it out also I have a merch coupon code
coupon code Vegas to save on merch links
will be in the description so thanks
again for watching and I'll see you guys
soon